.
- J'avais appliqué pour une
- C'est un bilan de santé qui
ne devait être qu'une formalité
pour Marc Maillet, mais le
résultat a cet changé sa vie.
MARC MAILLET, dir., Association
canadienne des greffés, N-É
- Ils ont découvert que mes
Ils ont découvert que j'avais
e e e maladie du rein.
J'avais aucune idée que j'avais
des problèmes s s s s s s s s ss
reins ont cessé de fonctionner.
La dialyse est devenue
nécessaire en attente d'une
trois ans.
auauauaut toujours tu restes
autour, parce qu'à tous les deux
jours, t'as besoin de ôôôôôôôôô,
ainsi de suite. Alors toute ta
vie tourne autour de ton horaire
de dialyse. Ça affecte la
famille, ça affecte tout
- Mais vous, donc, c'est une
nouvelle vie depuis le don?
- Ah oui, oui.rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr.
- Pour lui, mais surtout pour
tous ceux qui vivent à leur
tour dans l'attente, le nouveau
province est porteur d'espoir.
Au coeur de la réfor
le principe de consentement
présumé.
on considère que tous ceux dans
vivivivivince qui répondent aux
exigences médicales ont consenti
au don d'organes , explique le
médecin responsable du
programme. Ceux qui s'y opposenn
défunt sont aussi touj
consultés, pour s'assurer que
la personne  n'avait jamais
malaise lié au don d'organes.
Un autre objectif du programme
de 2021, c'est que le nombre de
donneurs refluxuxuxuxuxux le tax
d'appui au don d'organes qui
est exprimé dans la population.
de tissus, comme des cornées
ou des valves cardiaques,
ont été recensés en Nouvelle-
par rapport à 2020.
28 personnes décédéeiiiiii
été identifées comme potentiels
donneurs d'organes consentants.
mais révélateurs de l'ampleur
du défi.
Plus de 57 000 personnes ont
qurefusé que leurs organes soiet
57575757575757 000 personnes ont
quant à elles officiellement
refusé que leurs oC'C'C'C'C'C'C%
de la population, soit moins
que ce que les responsables
du programme avaient prévu.
Mais même un an après son
adeseseseseseseses Néo-écossais
ignorent encore l'existence de
la nouvelle loi.urururururururuu
programme de consentement
présumé depuis l'an passé
pour le don d'organes?
- Une méconnaissance qui ne
rassure pas cette experte.
hospitalier, Université Montréal
- Ça soulève
des enjeux éthiques puis ça
pourrait faire que pour
ou ne prélève pas leurs organes,
mais que ça aille à l'encontre
de leur volonté.
D'autres provinces canadiennes
envisagent aussi d
le consentement présumé.
Ceux qui appuient le principe
- Adopter cette nouvelle loi, si
ça peut sauver deux personnes,
pour moi, ça vaut la peine.
seulement, 276 Canadiens sont
décédés dododododododododon
d'organes.
Ici Mathieu Papillo